-You all know
how to play "Charades."
Each player gets a turn giving
silent clues to their teammate.
30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We're gonna do four rounds,
and then the fifth round
is the Charades Showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
The teams are me and Gal
versus Patty and Tariq.
Gal, why don't you
start us off tonight
and let's show them
how it's done.
-You got it.
-Patty, you can go right there.
Tariq.
-Just watch the magic.
-Yeah, watch the magic.
Exactly.
You guys, pick a number,
any number for Gal?
-Number?
[ Audience shouting ]
7.
-All right, we can do this.
-Remember, the "Seinfeld"
episode with seven -- Seven?
Never mind.
[ Laughter ]
You remember.
-Okay.
-Um...
Okay.
-Yeah.
Oh, we got this.
I can feel it already.
-Okay.
-I can feel the confidence.
Oh, it's a song.
Three words.
First word.
Belt.
[ Laughter ]
Waist.
Hips.
"Hips Don't Lie"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ I'm on tonight ♪♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got to follow that one.
♪♪ Hips don't lie ♪♪
Oh, yeah.
Shakira!
[ Laughter ]
Shakira, Shakira.
-All right, I'm going for 9.
9. Okay.
Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, wait,
this is very common.
It's a film.
Of course you would get that.
-Hush, please!
[ Laughter ]
Three words.
"The Karate Kid"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-"Karate kid?"
You didn't even say
"Kung Fu Panda"?
It's like Tariq just got -- -
-I bet you already --
You already probably knew
where I was going, right?
-That was more kung fu
than karate.
I don't know what that was.
Come on.
-Okay, you got it, you got it.
-All right, what number?
Let's do this.
-4!
-I heard a very confident 4
out there.
Oooh.
-Okay.
Shoo --
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Telepathic connection.
-Okay, ready for this?
-Okay. I hope.
-Okay. Um...
-Film.
Three words.
-"Kung Fu Panda."
-Yeah, right?
[ Laughter ]
All right, ready?
-One.
Single. One. No.
-First word.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's short and small -- end.
Three words, number three.
A chicken. Chicken.
Goose.
Dance.
Very funny dance.
[ Buzzer ]
-I couldn't use any sounds.
-What was it?
-"The Mighty Ducks."
-Ha-ha!
-Terrible, terrible.
I know, I know.
-Not so mighty.
-Who said 4?
-The crowd is trying not to boo
right now.
Oh, it's terrible, oh.
-That's okay,
we have another chance.
-I could have done mighty,
I could have done --
how do you do duck?
-Uh, you did this.
Oh, duck.
How do you do that?
Yeah.
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Is it me?
-All right.
-Okay.
One word.
-Oh, no, that's easy.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-"Arrival." "Arrival."
-Oh, that's a good guess.
Wait, are you -- what?
[ Laughter ]
-Time out.
-Don't even look at that.
What was that?
-Werewolf.
Uh, wait. Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
I, uh --
[ Buzzer ]
-Is it "Coco"?
-"Godzilla?"
-It was "Twilight."
-"Twilight"?
-"Twilight"? Oh, that's hard.
-I was acting like a werewolf,
a vampire --
-"Twilight."
-The light.
-It looked like a dinosaur.
-Oh, my gosh.
All right,
now this is the showdown.
-Oh, the showdown, right.
-Oh, God, okay.
-Patty, you and Gal get up.
-All right.
-Now you both do the same clue.
And we both guess.
Whichever team gets it
wins the whole shebang.
-Oh, so Team Tariq wins.
Got it.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-We're gonna do it.
I promise you.
-Okay. Cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, wait, wait. Stop!
She started already.
-Okay, so look at her in
the meantime because I didn't.
-Okay, ready?
-Ready.
-It's a song.
-Song. Yeah.
-I'm a monster. Dragon.
"Godzilla."
-Attack. Love.
-Hair, hair.
I'm a panther, lion, tiger.
"Eye of the Tiger."
Tiger -- I'm a tiger.
-"The Lion Sleeps Tonight."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness! That's how --
We redeemed ourselves.
-Yes.
-We did it!
Gal Gadot, right there!
Patty Jenkins!
Tariq Trotter!